Speaker 1: Welcome everybody. Most of you know,
you know, if you know me, if you know my show,
you know, I don't care about political party, yes,
I'm on the left. And right now, that means I
Speaker 2: mostly vote for candidates who
Speaker 1: happen to be
Speaker 2: Democrats.
Speaker 1: But I see political
Speaker 2: parties aside
Speaker 1: from their general platform
and views on issues, really as
organisms or entities that seek
Speaker 2: to justify
Speaker 1: and perpetuate their own existence.
They're not that different from corporations
in a lot of ways.
Speaker 2: So I don't
Speaker 1: care about defending Democrats
when they do bad things, I just call things
the way I see them. And today I have to call
out Joe Biden's White House press secretary,
Jen Psaki. And every time I do this, even though
Speaker 2: people
often write to me and say, David,
Speaker 1: I like that even though you're
on the left, you just tell it to us like it
is as you see it, when what I happen to see is
someone on the left not behaving correctly.
Sometimes people get mad and say, David,
you shouldn't be talking about this. Well,
listen, Jen Psaki does some things well,
and she does other things not so well. And
early on in her press secretary ship, when
she would be unprepared for a question, I would
say it. And then the next time she'd be prepared,
and I would say she was better prepared this time.
And here is something that's really not good.
Few days ago, Jen Psaki was asked about
Speaker 2: what about like maybe
Speaker 1: sending COVID tests to people's homes,
you know, to stop the spread. The tests are not
widely available as much as we would like.
They're expensive in many ways. What about
sending people tests? And she kind of laughed
it off scornfully by saying, what? So we're
just going to start sending people free tests.
Speaker 2: So let's look at that video from
a few days ago. Look at what we've done.
Speaker 3: Over the course of time, we've
quadrupled the size of our testing plan. We've cut
the cost significantly over the past few months.
And this effort to to push to ensure insurers
are able to get your your tests refunded means
one hundred and fifty million Americans will be
able to get free tests. We can't, though why not
just make them free and give them out and have
them available everywhere? Should we just send
one to every American? Maybe then then what? Then
what happens if if every American has one test,
how much does that cost? And then what happens
after that? All I know is that other countries
seem to be making them available for in
greater quantities, for less money. Well,
I think we share the same objective, which is
to make them less expensive and more accessible,
right? Every country is going to do that
differently. And I was noting that again,
our tests go through the FDA approval process.
Speaker 1: It is absolutely true that the
United States has failed on making at home
tests cheap and accessible and getting them
into people's hands. And the answer is yes.
Send everybody tests. Wow, that would be an
amazing thing to do. Consider what the savings
would be, given how expensive it is on average
for people to be hospitalized for COVID.
Speaker 2: Think about the savings now.
Speaker 1: I don't mean necessarily send them to
people who haven't even asked for them. There's no
doubt that in the U.S., with the environment that
we have, there are people who would receive the
tests and put them in the trash. So I'm not saying
just mail them out willy nilly, but set up a
Speaker 2: website to send
Speaker 1: people free tests
and send them out when people request
them. But she's right about one part.
If we send each person one test, what is that
really going to do? That's true, which is why
we should actually make it easy for people to sign
up and give them five tests, give them 10 tests.
This is how you get people who are
exposed regularly to identify cases
early and get them staying home. My sister
right now has COVID. She's in high school.
Why did she end up with it? Well, part of it
is there was a slow process for getting the
Speaker 2: classmate who is believed
Speaker 1: to have been the spreader tested
Speaker 2: and to report
Speaker 1: the results of that
Speaker 2: test. So it's a great idea, actually.
Speaker 1: So a few days go by and then Jen Psaki
Speaker 2: gets another shot
Speaker 1: at the same question,
and she does take a different approach.
Good for her. She seems to recognize
Speaker 2: that first
Speaker 1: answer was a
botched answer. The problem is she ends up reading
a pre-written answer, which is a lot of words with
very little meaning. Take a look
Speaker 2: at her next
Speaker 1: answer to the question
Speaker 4: is the White House's position on
this simply a cost analysis? Or are there other
reasons why the administration doesn't think
that sending tests COVID 19 tests
to all Americans is a good strategy?
Speaker 3: Well, let me let me give you an
overarching, comprehensive understanding of how
we're approaching this. To give you a sense and
I appreciate the questions. In February, we wrote
new guidance to make insurers cover asymptomatic,
asymptomatic PCR and point of care tests critical
to helping the majority of Americans who have
private insurance not worry about burdensome test
costs. We quadrupled the number of free pharmacy
testing sites with a priority on vulnerable
communities, and we've also secured funding
from the rescue plan invested in hardest hit
areas $10 billion for schools to conduct testing,
nearly $1 billion for rural clinics and hospitals,
and toward the summer. We also planned for the
school year, ensuring school districts had the
resources to set up a testing program to ensure
kids stayed in school. We also doubled down our
work to get testing to congregate settings that
were more vulnerable and where demand was was
higher. And as we've seen at home, tests
become more in demand. We've taken steps
on that front to make them free. So if you have
private insurance, we're making sure you'll get
reimbursed by your insurer for at home testing.
Speaker 1: All right. So you get the idea,
there's like another minute, but I'm not going to
play it all for you because it's this pre-written,
not very substantive answer. And it became
since we aren't going to send people free tests.
I'm going to read a bunch of stuff for
you that we've done, which doesn't include
free tests and is not going to
Speaker 2: include free tests.
Speaker 1: There are places that are doing
the free testing thing. Monroe County, New
Speaker 2: York is doing
Speaker 1: it to some degree
in Colorado. I believe if you have kids in school,
there's a way to get free tests. In Seattle,
there is a test delivery system
Speaker 2: and of course, in other
Speaker 1: countries, look
at what's happening in the UK
Speaker 2: in terms of people's ability to
Speaker 1: get free tests. So the good part
is eventually Jen Psaki figured out that first
answer was no good scornfully laughing off what
we're just going to send people free tests. Yes,
that was not good. So she changed her attitude,
but she then came back
Speaker 2: with, you know,
Speaker 1: something that clearly is
Speaker 2: not thinking
Speaker 1: nearly big enough
and a sort of prewritten
Speaker 2: answer communicating very,
Speaker 1: very little. One of the ways
that we can normalize more to what
we had before the pandemic, which
the right wants to do. And at least the
Biden administration wants to be able to do
in order to help the economy and so on and so
forth. It's make sure that we can easily figure
out who has COVID and free testing would be a
major, major piece of that. It's funny because
her new answer the pre-written two minute
Speaker 2: answer that I played one minute of for
you. It is better in that it's less offensive,
Speaker 1: it's less free tests. Get the hell
out of here, it's less of that. But it doesn't
actually get us anywhere closer to just sending
people free tests, which is abundantly clear they
have no interest in or intention of doing so. She
was prepared because she knew that first answer
was no good. But it doesn't seem like they're
going to do the free test guys. And this is one
of the differences in a lot of other countries,
the accessibility
Speaker 2: and the
Speaker 1: low or no cost
testing options that are there.